And now that we have our years in addition to our update function,
let's put them together in setInterval.
The syntax for
setInterval is that the first argument it expects is a function to run.
And the second argument is the number of milliseconds for
the interval to run at.
So for this example we'll run this anonymous function every second or
every 1,000 milliseconds starting one second from when set interval gets called.
And the way to stop an interval, so it doesn't go on forever, is to remember in
a variable, what interval you set, and inside our function for the interval.
We need to put our code that runs the update function and
pass it one year at a time.
In our code here, we're creating an index, so we know which year we're at.
Inside our function is called at the specified setInterval of
1,000 milliseconds.
We're running our update function with the specified index
to get the correct year from our years array and
running update with that year incrementing the index by 1.
And then if the index happens to be greater than then number of
elements in our years array, meaning we've going to through every year,
past the year interval, the JavaScript function clearInterval.
ClearInterval is simply a built in JavaScript function,
that takes as a single argument, an interval variable created with setInterval.
And stops it so that we don't run for
ever, update after update of the World Cup map.
To make this a little bit more clear, calling setInterval,
it returns an interval object which we're remembering in our year_interval
variable which we then are going to pass to clearInterval to stop or
function from getting called every 1,000 milliseconds.
And now let's save our file and go back to our browser and
see how our map animates.